but first up he was a war hero he
certainly was an activist senator a
Secretary of State and the 2004
Democratic nominee for president whose
new memoir is every day is extra John
Kerry
[Applause]
yes when they were giving you the
standing ovation I just next to you like
basking in it like some of its getting
on me actually actually I noticed that
you sat down very quickly but listen
it's always an honor I have you lighted
to be with you talk to you anything with
you but I must say I read Trump's tweet
about you today yeah and apparently
you're bad very very bad with big
letters be like a BA D it that bad what
did you do John Kerry that was bad I
think I told the truth
[Applause]
yeah our first president that I know of
who spends more time reading his Twitter
likes then his briefing books or the
constitution of you know yeah he's
saying that you're a bad person because
you met with your out of office and you
met with the Iranian or talk to the
Iranian I did yeah yeah absolutely
but everybody everybody does well Henry
Kissinger for 40 years have been
traveling to Russia traveling to the
China talk to her the leaders there's
absolutely nothing you know unusual
about it a conversation I think he
really ought to be worrying about is
Paul Manafort with Muller it's giant
I mean it's it really is giant and and
soon you will be hearing him say that's
the worst deal that's ever been made but
you know when you stop and think I mean
it's gone from the art of the deal to
the art of the squeal I've never seen I
honestly have never seen anything quite
like it the anonymous op-ed the the
Woodward book or the chronology of
everything that's been happening and
it's tough you know we we've always
relied on our democracy survive getting
better being stronger when people tell
the truth and we're based on the truth
democracy is based on the truth and
unfortunately we have a president
literally for whom the truth and nothing
but the truth you know the truth the
whole truth nothing but the truth is
three different things and you don't
even know what they are
he's he's he has I I don't want to get
into a real riff on this but I got to
tell you he's
I mean John we Harry he is he really is
the rare combination of a eight-year-old
boy I mean he's got the maturity of an
eight-year-old boy with the insecurities
of a teenage girl I mean it can be mean
but when you talk about the truth I mean
it's so interesting
you're a truth teller and when you're
talking in glowing terms about the truth
but people don't really like truth
tellers well do that too I mean these
people like me but not even always them
because when you really tell the truth
like you did about Vietnam that's what
they really hated you for when they in
2004 which was kind of the beginning of
fake news director the campaign they ran
against you that's great a true war hero
and karl rove said by the end of this
election they won't know which side he
was on right I'm sure you remember that
I remember they don't you told the truth
when you got back from Vietnam I did
tell the never appreciated in its own
time well sometimes choices you make are
not appreciated in their own time but I
am very comfortable that I not only told
the truth I believe all those those
veterans who came back from Vietnam many
of them had very difficult time and they
joined in telling the truth and I am
convinced that we brought the war to a
close sooner that we saved lives by
telling the truth and all you have to do
is look and see Ken Burns's recent film
that documents you know how early the
lying began yeah so I'm proud of that
and I'm proud of the fact that you're
gone McCain and I then we're able to
come together
John exhibited a kind of you know large
personality that could forgive and move
on and knew the importance of working at
bipartisan fashion and so John and I
together decided we're going to end the
war at home and abroad and we spent 10
years and we made peace with Vietnam and
for the better part not everybody but
for the most part by bringing 700
remains of
service men home from Vietnam so
families could have closure I think we
went a long way to making peace here at
home
the kids a long time ago when it was and
you know your book is a memoir it's must
be bittersweet when you I'm probably
approaching the memoir writing years and
I just I just was reminded you've been
here for 16 years yeah you know here and
by the way I was with your producer just
before I came out and I stopped him in
mid-sentence and I said you want to know
the stupidest thing that's on TV today
and I pointed to the TV and there was a
weather guy out there getting soaked I'm
so glad you said because first of all
it's a local weather story also it was a
category 5 at the beginning of the week
with true they were thrilled about
because they love that Americans love to
watch a palm tree swaying like that you
could show the footage from any year but
when it got downgraded to a category one
they didn't downgrade the coverage not
sure well there's so much consequence
where it's going they made that they
made the commitment they had everybody
out there if I wrote a book about cable
news would be called fool in the rain so
but I mean you were in Vietnam then you
know 9/11 and that would been doing that
ever since now we're back to the
Russians we're always mixing it up with
somebody is it us is it just being the
biggest baddest you know we're live
we're living in a very complicated world
today and it's a world in which we play
I think the essential role normally this
is not normal we what I learned as
Secretary of State I knew it but what I
learned in a very personal tactile way
was the degree to which people all over
the world look to us to help lead and we
lead we're on the brink of having the
first generation of children born
aids-free in Africa that's because of
our photo we did we are
you know we faced Ebola I remember
sitting in the Situation Room in the
White House we were told a million
people are going to die in the next four
months and President Obama said no you
know we're gonna send three thousand
American troops over there which had its
own risks we worked with the French we
worked with the British and each took
the country in West Africa
we stopped Ebola in its tracks I mean
these are you can run around the world I
said during our administration that I
believe that we dealt with more crises
simultaneously with greater impact on
behalf of our country than in any time
in history from the South China Sea to
to to what's happening at Central Asia
Afghanistan and Pakistan what was
happening in Syria now it didn't all
have the outcomes that we wanted to
achieve and I write in my book I mean
Syria remains the open wound it's a
failure of the entire international
community to to make the peace but but
we tried we cared I always said to my
folks in the department don't be scared
to get caught trying right and that's
what we did and the trying saved lives
we got a ceasefire here or ceasefire
there for those people in that ceasefire
for three weeks or a month or two months
they're alive today and they wouldn't
have been if we hadn't done that but I
always argued we needed some way of
holding us out a little more accountable
so what do we do when we only have two
parties and when only one side plays
decently you lost a very close election
one state 65,000 votes and one right
they could have contested it Al Gore
could have went a lot further with his
protest Al Gore was elected president as
wasn't counted what I'm saying
it's sort of a Hobson's choice and you
don't want to act like them but we seem
to be getting our ass kicked because
we're the only ones playing by rules
Al Gore gave that debate book back
remember when he got the debate book and
he said no this isn't cricket do you
think that if in 2020 Trump is running
again and he finds out that Putin helped
him he probably asking for his help but
if he say he wasn't doing that if he
just you think he'd reported of course
not no what do you do when one only one
side plays by rules well if you believe
in America and you believe in the
decency of our democracy and our system
I don't think I think Richard Nixon
proved this I think other presidents
have proven it historically politics
life proves it if you you know if you
sleep with dogs you come up with fleas
if you if you if you go down to the end
on all of us well but there we can win
by offering Americans a better and real
agenda that improves the lives not of
the billionaires but of all Americans if
we do that if we go out and show the
ways in which they're attacking
democracy i I've always believed in the
truth I believe in it now and I think if
you hold people up to account publicly
that includes President Putin or little
green men running around in Ukraine or
wherever it is shed light on it push it
in all the four others are available to
you but you've got to honor the rule of
law because if you go outside of it it
won't have its meaning anymore when it
needs to and is deep you're right about
that well I believe it yeah
John Kerry good luck with the book it's
a terrific
nobody